dans le viseur du conseil
constitutionnel l'article 1 de la loi
via il imposait aux plateformes et
moteurs de recherche de retirer sous 24
heures les contenus manifestement
illicite
sous peine de sanctions pénales soit un
an d'emprisonnement et 250000 euros
damende les opérateurs de plate-forme en
huile sont tenues au regard de l'intérêt
général attaché au respect de la dignité
humaine de retirer ou de rendre
inaccessible dans un délai de 24 heures
après notification par une ou plusieurs
personnes
tout contenu contrevenants manifestement
aux dispositions mentionnées une
obligation que le conseil
constitutionnel a jugé incompatible avec
la liberté d'expression
il a considéré que cette mesure pouvait
inciter les opérateurs de plate forme en
ligne à retirer les contenus qui leur
sont signalés qu'il souhaite illicite ou
non
le législateur a porté à la liberté
d'expression et de communication une
atteinte qui n'est pas adaptée
nécessaire et proportionnée au but
poursuivi
destiné à renforcer la lutte contre la
haine raciste et antisémite qui prospère
sur internet
le texte porté par la députée lrm
laetitia avia devait entrer en
application au 1er juillet il avait reçu
un soutien fort du gouvernement
mais la décision du conseil
constitutionnel le vide quasiment de sa
substance en censurant la disposition
phare de la proposition de loi
un camouflet pour la députée lrm qui
décrivait ce dispositif comme le coeur
du texte et laetitia a réagi dans un
communiqué elle affirme poursuivre sa
démarche en continuant à lutter contre
les discours de haine sur internet est
la députée veut se servir de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel pour
construire une feuille de route et
améliorer le dispositif
et pour ti rival avocat au barreau de
paris spécialisée dans le droit
numérique il y avait un risque de sur
100 sûr concernant les amendes avec
cette loi à viard écoutez le il y avait
un risque de sur censure puisque les
amendes qui allait être infligée sans
recours sans possibilité de réaction
rapide puisque 24 heures c'est c'était
beaucoup trop haut trop court pour
pouvoir saisir un juge pour savoir
exactement ce qui était ou non
dépendants d'eux
manifestement du caractère manifestement
illicite d'un contenu donc il est clair
que les plateformes à l'est sur réagir
et les algorithmes allait être mis en
place de manière à pouvoir enlever tous
les contenus qu'ils allaient poser un
problème et donc censuré manifestement
les les
les internautes donc il est clair que
c'est les gars ça allait avoir une droit
de vie ou de mort sur les sur notre
expression ce qui n'était pas du tout
pas du tout envisageable
il est clair que là encore je le
rappelle lutter contre la haine sur
internet c'est très bien il faut le
faire mais il faut le faire en
respectant les règles de l'état de droit